hello everyone this video is a response
to cgp gray's painful take on traffic
now i don't have an issue with cgp gray
or his content in general but i do
believe that his video
entitled the simple solution to traffic
is wildly misinformed and propagates
some very harmful solutions both to
people
and to our built environment i've put a
link to his video in the description so
you can check it out yourself and make
sure that i don't misrepresent any of
his ideas
so let's get to it shall we in the video
cgp grey begins by laying out the main
problem with traffic in his opinion
coordination stuck at an intersection
you always watch unfold the fundamental
problem
of traffic on green the first car
accelerates and then
the next and then the next and then the
next and then you
only to catch the red had the cars
accelerated simultaneously you would
have made it through
coordination not cars is the problem
because we are monkey drivers with slow
reaction times and short attention spans
he posits that traffic could be vastly
improved if all cars could accelerate
and decelerate at the same time as if
they were connected to each other oh man
so far this sounds dangerous like a
train
cgp gray then proposes the first
practical solution
just don't tailgate stay in the middle
that should fix the problem right
of course not and cgp grey acknowledges
this so props to him that's
the simple solution to traffic getting
humans to change their behavior perhaps
by sharing this video to show
how and why traffic happens why
tailgaters are trouble and how we can
work together to make the roads
better for all the end except
yeah wishing upon a star that people are
better than they are
is a terrible solution every time cgp
grey then posits that we need a
structurally systematized solution wow
you mean
public transportate which is exactly
what self-driving cars are
oh and this right here is the main point
i'll be arguing against
that self-driving cars are a solution or
even the solution to our traffic
problems
so within the framework of self-driving
cars cgp grey proposes that once all
cars become self-driving we can finally
get rid of intersections
and so traffic will flow evenly and
nobody will have to sit in a traffic jam
now that being said
my question to you cgb grey is how in
the name of christ will a pedestrian
cross
this and this right here is my central
issue with this video really
it looks and sounds like having been
made by someone who if they want to go
running
take their suv from their copy paste
suburban home to the strip mall 10
kilometers away
and then take the escalator of the gym
stairs so that they can run on a
treadmill for half an hour
it's a terminally core brained mindset
as if cgp grey cannot imagine his life
without motorization
this becomes increasingly evident when
he goes on to say a solid lane of
self-driving cars
vastly increases throughput neat so if
until now 20
000 cars passed under your window every
day it's now going to be 60 000.
yay cgp then suggests that we should ban
humans from the road
and i'm assuming that this video is
talking about urban areas where clogged
intersections are a real problem and
interchanges aren't an option
and by banning humans from the road cgp
gray of course means
ban humans from driving but ironically
this would actually ban humans from the
roads physically in the sense that we
wouldn't even be allowed to cross it at
grade anymore off the road peasant
you're messing up our perfect
techno-future car flow
how dare you disrupt traffic with your
existence in this
settlement where people live if this
dystopian night i mean traffic solution
would become a reality
we would need to invest in a lot of
costly underground and overground
passages
you know the things every city is
desperately trying to get rid of because
they're horrible
they're awkward to climb and not
accessible for low mobility groups
unless you're willing to shell out tons
of money for elevators and it's not just
a problem for wheelchair-bound and older
people
imagine spraining your ankle at work or
something and then having to climb 10
flights of stairs just to get to the
grocery store
turning urban areas into obstacle
courses for pedestrians only benefits
drivers and make everyone else miserable
its peak 1960s city planning and cgp
grace video is from 2016
which is impressive separating cars from
people inside cities for a better
traffic flow leads to all kinds of
negative outcomes
and i know because this has been tried
before this is a picture of the area in
front of prague main station from back
in the day
as you can see it's this archaic low
capacity
very low efficiency very non-epic design
but thankfully some future visionaries
got their hands on it and turned it into
a high capacity
very high efficiency fast great separate
transit solution
and it also became one of the worst
places inside the entire city
beneath this 8 lane urban freeway there
is a network of underpasses that are
awkward to get to
but at night they offer a free mugging
experience if you are into that sort of
thing
but hey in the name of fixing traffic
who wouldn't want to walk down a dark
concrete hallway leaking of feces with
heavy traffic rumbling above
underpasses and overpasses are meant to
cement the dominance of cars in our
living spaces and nothing else
the only group they benefit inside urban
areas is drivers
some people say they are actually good
for pedestrians though because they are
safer
but they are only quote unquote safe
because the roads are dangerous
and that's because of individual motor
traffic aka cars
and nothing else you know cars are
literally the worst kind of
transportation you can have
even electric cars and that's because
outside of pollution the biggest problem
is geometry
one car will fit inside a city one
million won't
not unless you bulldoze entire
neighborhoods to make way for urban
freeways and tear down half the inner
city to build parking lots
no matter how well you coordinate your
cars they will still back up if they
don't fit inside the city
rolling around in two tons of metal and
plastic per 1.5 or so people
is simply not sustainable period this is
where the story begins
and ends there is no getting around this
issue it's either a car friendly city or
a livable city
you can only pick one also one thing
that cgb grey ignores completely is just
how vulnerable a network of self-driving
cars is to sabotage
imagine if on a road like this someone
hacked into the control system of just
three or four
cars and then sometimes a command to
make a sharp turn into the oncoming lane
the result would be a massive pileup and
a significant death toll
and even if most other cars could stop
in time the road would still be blocked
for hours
do this at some key intersections at the
same time at rush hour and you'll
paralyze an entire city do this in
multiple cities and logistics routes at
the same time
and you'll paralyze an entire economy
and if you think this is some kind of
science fiction speculation you would be
wrong
this is already happening just a few
weeks before making this video
there was a hacker attack on the
colonial pipeline in the u.s causing
massive fuel shortages and general panic
but what if we developed some very
highly advanced countermeasures what if
we create an encryption
so good that it would take a hundred
years to crack using the ibm mainframe
that encryption will work until the
first quantum computer comes along able
to break it in a few minutes
imagine a geopolitical rival like china
secretly developing a high performance
quantum computer
and then letting it loose on the west
imagine massive deadly pileups not just
in a few places but in every
intersection of every city of every
developed country on earth
or if you don't want to go that large
scale imagine taking over just a few
cars and ramming them into the
president's motorcade in an
assassination
attempt or taking over a 40-ton tanker
truck and running it into some
government building or a central
hospital or into a pillar of some
strategically important bridge or
something we don't yet realize the
enormous risks that self-driving cars
will pose
there'll be just another i.t system and
as such hackable
we are reaching a point where we need to
reconsider whether pure tax solutions
are a good idea
like how this man found out during a
google service outage
he writes i'm sitting here in the dark
in my toddler's room because the light
is controlled by google home
rethinking a lot right now
self-driving cars are not the solution
to traffic they can be very useful in
many cases but they are not some silver
bullet
so what's the actual solution to traffic
allow me to explain after a quick word
from today's sponsor
atlas vpn suppose you want to check out
top gear on netflix
a show about these archaic and
inefficient vehicles that we used to
think were the solution to mobility in
some dark past
but would you look at that it's not
actually there it's behind a region lock
and to bypass it you need a vpn
atlas vpn encrypts your data and hides
your virtual location
once you connect to their vpn server
you'll be given a new ip and dns address
to access all the content that has been
locked away from you
if you want to see what ease or isn't
available in your location head on over
to unogs.com they have a neat database
with all the movies and their
availabilities on netflix
atlas vpn is available on basically any
device
it's super user friendly and easy to use
and they currently have a huge sale
going on for a limited time only
so how much is it per month is it ten
dollars eight dollars
six dollars it's actually one dollar and
39 cents for three entire years
that and a 30-day money-back guarantee
you can take advantage of this deal by
using the affiliate link in the
description or in the comment section
below
thank you for checking out atlas vpn ads
like this help support what i do
and now back to the video previously on
this video
so what's the actual solution to traffic
plain and simple
instead of the mindless promotion of
self-driving cars we should start
planning cities in a way that you won't
actually need a car for your day-to-day
existence
i've lived in european cities for my
whole life and i've never needed a car
to get around
only for rare occasions maybe like
hauling furniture or something
in the meantime we should continue
taking back our cities from cars
street by street square meter by square
meter we should focus on building
walkable neighborhoods get rid of giant
strip malls at the edges of cities that
encourage car use
demolish urban freeways and rearrange
the suburbs to increase their density
and walkability
measures like this will limit urban
sprawl making public transit much more
viable and efficient
it'll be a virtuous circle that will
make all our lives better
and if you happen to belong to the top
one percent meaning these measures would
make your life
somewhat less comfortable tough [ __ ]
this is the simple solution to fix
traffic not trying to make a broken
system a bit more efficient
through sheer tech but getting rid of it
in favor of something better
because even if every single car becomes
self-driving and we somehow make it 100
sabotage proof
and every single road starts operating
in this hyper-efficient mode
all that would have the same effect as
adding more lanes
i.e increasing capacity it's called
induced demand
cgp and i think you should look into it
before making a video about how to fix
traffic because no one has ever fixed
traffic by adding more capacity
and self-driving cars will not be an
exception either
thank you for watching please like and
subscribe and don't forget to check out
my patreon if you think this kind of
content is worth your money and i'll be
seeing you
next time